yeah i just feel like you can feel okay
i will tell you when you know you've
reached
the generation gap right it's that point
it's that point because i
i remember right when i thought yeah
i'll i'll always be up for a tequila
or sambuca or jagerbomb and then
somewhere along in life i reached like
mid-20s and i'm just like
maybe they're just better ways to get
drunk other than
doing these shots i don't know i don't
know you just kind of be like do i
do i want to be drunk
i remember i used to think like i would
look at like all the dads at a pub right
yeah
i'm just like they're just sitting there
talking
yeah with a beer in their hands that
doesn't sound
fun and now i'm just like i wish for
that more than anything right now
exactly right exactly right um i
remember i remember thinking like when i
was in university
i remember thinking i'm never going to
be like that i'm not i'mma still be
doing shots when i'm 50. let's go
i was like that when i was like 22. i
just gave up at like 21. yeah i finished
with university
town to be edged uh time to be an adult
it's gonna be a boring functioning adult
it's terrible isn't it yeah um yeah i
mean i remember recently i went to my
like some of my first wine events um
went to a wine tasting event and that's
how you
that's how you know that's that's
privilege that's how you know you're
like
i've reached that age when i'm just like
okay how about wine tasting
and uh yeah i remember taking conor to
one as well one time and
like i'm so this one time like the
people at this vine event
are exactly the people you expect to be
at this winery
everyone's like everyone's in like their
[ __ ] 40s or 50s everyone's like a
[ __ ] investment banker or something
you know something like with a monocle
and top hat
yeah yeah that was base that's basically
like the main guy running the event is
like this really old french dude
who you could see in like a monaco on
top hat right
and uh i remember so i was with sydney
and so he was you know it's it's like a
very intimate event
so he would go around asking people what
what they do and of course when when
they go
they go to us we mentioned youtuber and
like obviously people perk the [ __ ] up
right right and of course he goes to
sydney and asks what she does
and sydney very just very tastefully
says that you know she does
videos about anime and manga and
japanese culture and then he asks her
for her youtube channel
and she gives it to him and then he goes
oh let me just search this up and i've
never seen like the life flash before
someone's eyes as fast as i've seen
like cindy go no no no no don't don't do
that don't do that
but the best the best part was so
um so so at this one event you know it's
uh it's it's a room full of people
they're very
very prim and proper yeah it's it's a
very i would say it is a very posh room
yeah of course and so um we go up to
have like i think like our
third or fourth glass of wine that we're
trying and
so there's this word in french that
means cheers
you say in english as well though do you
say in the uk as well
okay so so what he uh so you know it's
it's that joke
that the guy makes every single [ __ ]
time because it's like it's like a very
obvious joke right
so he goes okay everyone everyone say
chinchin and then the entire room is
just silent
except i just here next to me sydney go
like it is not quiet at all she's burst
out
and everyone starts laughing i remember
just sitting there like [ __ ]
i'm with those guys
oh my god to be fair it is pretty funny
yeah that you came to like chinchin yeah
chinchin
did you ever say that yeah in the uk
people always say chinchin like before
you down a pint or something like
chinchin
and you down it i've never heard that
before maybe it's like a northerner
thing i don't know people always said
that they say that in
italy too don't they as well yeah i
believe so maybe that's where yeah
oh god we didn't explain the joke if you
don't know uh chinchin
uh sounds like oh chinchin which means
penis yeah yeah
basically you're just saying peepee yeah
where like there's literally security
every like 10 meters to check where
you're in the right place and then
each [ __ ] lap it was it like some
fancy hotel or something oh my god yeah
i always feel really out of place
because i'm just like a child so i'm
like yeah right
i'm like i don't belong whenever i go to
like any fancy restaurant it doesn't
matter where it is
i'm just like i shouldn't be here yeah
yeah exactly i need a [ __ ] t-shirt
yeah i'm here to taste this yeah i just
wanted i just wanted wine you know i i
felt
like every time i go to one of these
those events or especially like a
company party
yeah like i i i've never i never felt i
never feel more self-conscious than
whenever everyone around me is just
wearing suits and i'm just like
meanwhile i had to bust out this like
[ __ ]
wrinkly ass like college shirt from like
the bottom of my wardrobe i was like oh
[ __ ]
it's great you can go to these events
and then people will tell you about how
rich their parents are it's really fun
it's really really fun i love it it's
great
it's just so depressing i won't [ __ ]
hear about how your dad owns ten
companies
you guys you guys should have like gone
in the [ __ ] jojo suits right you
should have just like fully committed
like
like proper like wear a monocle and like
a top coat
i don't think monocles have been in
fashion since the [ __ ] place well you
can bring it bring
bring back the monocle just cosplay the
monopoly man exactly
that's what i'm gonna do fake mustache
and everything just i wanna get gray
hair so i can become the monopoly man
before it falls out and drink wine yeah
exactly
oh my god oh my god